bonsoir sonore écoute j'ai entendu
alexis michalik s'essayer à quelques
verres où je me suis dit que j'aurais
peut-être l'audace de faire parler allez
c'est bon je peux super
pour ce que j'en connais le casteur de
ma vie c'est moins chanteur de mon
parking on me juge est doué oublions
sacrifices les années le travail acteur
et musicien ne parle que de jouer chacun
sa partition quand les rêves nous
retarde la vie inspiré l'auteur l'auteur
inspire la vie paroles qu'on peut dans
ses notes qu'on photographie bref les
images s'écoute la musique se regarde il
ya eu ces idées et ces mots et ces sons
très souvent dès l'enfance ils nous ont
abordés j'ai consenti à tous sans avoir
le soupçon du temps qu'il me faudrait
pour tous les accorder des mélodies qui
rêvent d'expression qu'on libère s'il
tentait qu'on vous laisse partager un
cauchemar qui joueraient des deux pieds
et tellement de travers qu'on pourrait
suggérer qu'il a iniqué sa mère alors à
toutes ses nuits blanches et semaine
écourtée toutes ces inspirations qui
naissent quand il fait noir cette
musique on entend qu'il s'agit d'écouter
pour qu'à la fin du bal une couronne les
césar
[Applaudissements]